hey I am inspired by the heartwarming
concern over whether I might be losing
my citizenship status here in the United
States because of this Trump
administration initiative and I'm here
to tell you I don't think I'm gonna be
losing my citizenship an example email
to me over the weekend said hey David
Trump is going to take away citizenship
from people who came to the US legally
but have a criminal record
you were once arrested for underage
drinking are you in trouble
might you be losing your citizenship and
what people are writing it about is an
announcement from the Trump
administration from about a week or so
ago that they're going to look at
stripping citizenship from people who
were not born citizens but who were
naturalized as citizens because of
regular irregularities related to their
naturalization so first and foremost
this is a really rare thing since 1990
only three hundred civil cases asking
for the deed naturalization of citizens
have been carried out but it's true that
the Trump administration is ramping up
efforts to do this so let's kind of take
it in pieces so we understand it this is
not immigrants who have been naturalized
who then were arrested for drunk driving
or larceny or whatever right this is
people who have irregularities in their
naturalization meaning that they assumed
a new identity to avoid getting deported
or assumed a new identity to get a green
card or to get citizenship we're talking
about that type of irregularity so what
was my situation I moved to the United
States at age five when I was 16 in the
year 2000 my parents became citizens of
the United States and I was not
automatically a citizen I had two
options I could go to the post office up
until age 18 and just request a passport
and I would automatically become a
citizen because my parents had been made
citizens or if I waited until I turned
18 I would still be entitled to
citizenship whenever I wanted
automatically but I would have to go
through the full process on my own and
initially I had no plans to actually
become a citizen of the United States
when I was 16 but then George W Bush was
elected late in
year 2000 he was inaugurated in 2001 and
my parents said to me we don't know
what's gonna happen with immigration
policy and George W Bush we are now
citizens we're staying here you should
just do it so I did and I really
hesitated for a while because I kind of
felt like I would lose my Argentinian
identity if I became a citizen of the
United States but once I understood why
it made sense and what could be coming
with the Bush administration and once I
realized I live here my life is in the
United States I did it right when I was
17 years old much later when I was
twenty and a half just six months shy of
my 21st birthday I was caught holding a
beer which I had not even had a sip of
yet at a college party and I was
arrested I was never indicted I was sent
to some class about how drinking is bad
not a problem that I had fortunately and
that is now completely gone from my
record because it had been 10 years so
I'm okay I'm okay but there are people
who are being targeted for this yeah I
think you should be good so long as you
promise that you'll never drink underage
again exactly in which I've made that
promise a number of different times so
let's talk about what the Trump
administration is doing the Trump
administration can legally target people
who were naturalized under irregular
circumstances the truth is it's very
rare and we know that these are folks
who are less likely to commit crime if
you know that if you come to the
attention of law enforcement all of a
sudden the circumstances of your
naturalization might go public you are
more likely to avoid committing crimes
so that you don't get on the radar of
law enforcement in the first place so
I'm not saying ignore what people have
done if it's against the law what I'm
saying is that the amount of government
time and money required relative to the
benefit doesn't really make sense as
something that I would focus on but to
the hatreds you will be very
disappointed no indication at this time
that I am going to be shipped back to to
Argentina I hate to make them sad after
such a patriotic holiday but it doesn't
seem like it's going to happen